Prof: Miguel de
Cervantes died in Madrid on
April 23rd, 1616.
Remember that,
famously, Shakespeare died on
the same date;
not the same day,
because England and Spain were
following different calendars,
the difference of two or three
days.
In the last five years of his
life Cervantes saw published
The Exemplary Novels,
in 1613, The Voyage to
Parnassus,
which is a long poem of
essentially literary criticism,
where he reviews the writers of
the appeared.
That appeared in 1614.
Part II of the Quixote
appeared in 1615,
and also, in that year,
his volume of theater,
called Eight Plays and Eight
New Interludes Never before
Performed.
In 1617 The Trials of
Persiles y Sigismunda was
published posthumously.
Those plays he was able to
publish because of his newly
acquired fame,
and also because they had not
been very successful on the
stage,
except for the interludes.
Let me repeat a quotation from
the Casebook,
specifically from the
biographical essay by Manual
Durán that opens the
Casebook.
This is a quote that I have
read before, but I want to
repeat it;
it is a quote that also has
embedded a statement by
Ángel del Río,
which I think you may remember
his name in any case--
Ángel del Río--
that I think are appropriate as
we wind up our course.
But before I read you that
quote, let me read you the
following, also by Durán,
quote:
"Cervantes died in Madrid
on April 23rd,
1616 at peace with himself and
with the world,
having received the last
sacraments,
and was buried in the convent
of the Trinitarian Nuns.
He died without bitterness or
regrets since he had been fully
conscious of his merit,
indeed of his genius,
and was aware that his literary
creations would endure.
A writer cannot hope for a
greater source of
consolation."
Later, constructions and
reconstructions of that building
by the way led to the
disappearance of Cervantes
bones.
So we don't have Cervantes'
relics, his bones are lost.
I have been insisting on
Cervantes' knowledge of Don
Quixote's belonging--
awareness of Don Quixote's
belonging to the gallery of
great literary figures from the
classical past.
Most recently,
when, in the last lecture,
I spoke about that scene in the
last inn where they lodge,
and there are some wall
hangings with the figures of
Helen of Troy and Dido,
and Sancho makes the quip that
there will be images of Don
Quixote,
of themselves,
of Don Quixote and Sancho all
everywhere in the future,
and I underline that that is a
bet that Sancho has certainly
won.
Now, let me go to that longer
quote by Durán and del
Río,
who was--Ángel del
Río was the author of an
excellent history of Spanish
literature,
and as I said,
he taught for many years at
Columbia University;
he was a Spaniard:
"Objectively,
[says Durán]
Cervantes' life was not a
success story.
He was seldom in full control,
he was too poor,
for many years he lacked public
recognition.
Yet, as Ángel del
Río points out,
‘there is no reason to
lament [I'm quoting now the
Ángel del Río
quote within Durán's
quote]
Cervantes' misfortunes,
nor the mediocrity of his daily
life.'
He could thus through an
experience,
which is seldom obtained when
the writer is successful and
wealthy,
he could know,
observe, and feel the beat of
Spanish life in its greatness
and in its poverty,
in its heroic fantasy and in
the sad reality of an imminent
decadence.
He was to leave in his books
the most faithful image of this
life,
reflected in multiple
perspectives with bitter sweet
irony and penetrating
humor."
The allusion to decadence here
is that, for many years,
in the twentieth century
scholars studied the decadence
of the Spanish empire.
Remember that quote that I
brought,
and you must have read as you
read Elliot,
from Elliot,
about Cervantes straddling
those two moments of Spanish
history,
one of great triumph,
and then the beginnings of the
decline.
Now, Cervantes never attained
in his time the recognition of
Lope de Vega,
that writer I've mentioned so
many times.
Lope de Vega,
whom Cervantes criticized and
admired at the same time.
But Cervantes was a greater
writer than Lope,
and history has confirmed this
fact.
Though Lope deserves a place in
the western canon,
he should not be at the same
level as Cervantes.
I say that because Lope is
generally not very well known in
the English-speaking world,
and he's sort of--I don't think
he even appears in my good
friend Harold Bloom's The
Western Canon,
but that is not Lope's fault,
that is Harold's fault.
Lope never created the figure
of universal appeal like Don
Quixote.
Even if he wrote hundreds of
plays,
perhaps a thousand plays,
many among those plays are
masterpieces:
Fuenteovejuna,
El caballero de Olmedo,
and so forth.
They're masterpieces in their
own right, and Lope created
thousands of characters.
This is all true.
But he was not on the level of
Cervantes.
Ironically, though,
of course, in the period,
Lope was tremendously
successful.
His story is really a success
story: he was rich,
he had a great following,
and even his name was
synonymous with being good.
If you said,
it's "de Lope"
it means that something is
good;
so that's how successful he was.
He just lorded over the Spanish
literary landscape in the early
seventeenth century.
He fought in the Spanish
"Armada,"
he had many women,
mistresses, wives,
ten or fifteen children,
some of them legitimate,
and at the end of his life he
became a priest,
impregnated one of his
mistresses...
Really a life really worth a
movie.
In the meantime,
Cervantes was chugging along in
Madrid,
within blocks of each other in
but he was creating a work that
was superior to Lope's.
Now, the question to ask,
as we draw a balance at the end
of the course,
is if Cervantes would have
deserved such recognition if he
had not written the
Quixote but everything else
that he wrote.
Would we have such high regard
for Cervantes if he had only
published the rest of his work,
some of which I mentioned when
I was listing the books that he
published towards the end of his
life?
The answer has to be no,
the answer has to be no;
not by far, though.
He would have been acknowledged
as an important writer of short
novels on the basis of The
Exemplary Novels,
Novelas ejemplares--I'll
talk about that later.
He was also the author of a
mediocre pastoral romance,
Galatea.
Remember, that he mentions it
in the--
he has the characters mention
it in the scrutiny of the books,
and he himself has some
critical things to say about
that pastoral romance,
and still towards the end of
his life,
in the very last year,
he was still thinking of
writing a second part of
Galatea,
but it was a mediocre work with
flashes of brilliance that
announced the Quixote,
but that are important because
of that,
not in themselves.
He was also the author of that
very uneven and very ambitious
Byzantine romance called The
Trials of Persiles y
Sigismunda.
I put this on the board several
times, so I don't have to do it
again.
This is a very odd work,
as Byzantine romances tend to
be,
and Cervantes thought,
he was deluded into thinking
that this was going to be the
culmination of his work,
his best work.
Well, he was wrong.
Authors are often wrong about
the worth of what they write,
and he certainly was wrong
about this.
The book is missing most of the
qualities that we admire in
the Quixote;
it's a very long book.
It lacks a central figure as
compelling as the mad knight,
except for some episodes in
Spain that have sort of a
realistic cast;
the geography is strange and
abstract;
it begins in the snow and
icebound regions of the North
Pole and finishes in Rome,
of course.
The dialogues are stilted;
they're not like the dialogues
in the Quixote,
where Sancho speaks in his very
folksy way;
and it is a very digressive
novel.
It has, again,
because Cervantes was the
author of the Quixote,
some moments that we see as
being brilliant,
and some odd things that...
For instance,
the characters carry around
banner,
like painting,
depicting their adventures,
so that whenever somebody asks
them where they have been,
they just unfurl this banner
and, there is,
their adventures.
It's very funny that way;
it has moments like that.
Again, but, as with
Galatea,
the Persiles is
important because it was written
by the author of the
Quixote.
As a playwright,
Cervantes was a master in the
comic one-act interludes,
the entremeses that I
have spoken about,
which show many features in
common with the Quixote,
particularly the funny parts of
the Quixote,
the slapstick parts of the
Quixote,
but his plays were stiff and
neoclassical because Cervantes
followed the rules that the
preceptistas,
those who had read Aristotle's
Poetics,
were promoting at the time.
You remember the discussions
among the characters,
I think it is chapter XLVIII of
Part I,
especially involving the Canon
of Toledo,
about the plays being written
at the time,
where Cervantes,
through his characters,
is criticizing Lope for not
following those rules.
He did, and then his plays were
duds;
they were just--some are okay,
but they're not that good.
It is one of those ironies of
literary history that Cervantes
was so wildly imaginative and
daring in prose fiction,
was so timid and conservative
when it came to the theater...
A mystery.
This is why you cannot just
list authors;
you have works,
you have to list works,
when you are making a hit
parade like the one Harold Bloom
makes in The Western
Canon.
So the high point of Cervantes'
production other than the
Quixote was Exemplary
Novels,
or Stories,
as they're called in the
translation that you are using.
This is a terminological
problem that I have explained
before.
The word
"novela"
that we have in Spanish for
novel today, did not exist then.
"Novela"
was
"nouvelle,"
that is,
a short novel,
or a long short story,
like the ones we have read:
Rinconete and
Cortadillo,
The Glass Graduate,
and the ones that are included
in Part I of the Quixote.
These are the Novelas
ejemplares.
Some of these short novels are
true masterpieces of the genre
and can stand next to the
greatest stories by Cervantes'
Italian predecessors,
of course, Giovanni Boccaccio,
whom I have mentioned many
times,
and Matteo Bandello,
whom I have also mentioned
before.
Now, I have mentioned them when
we discussed some of these
novels, mainly The Glass
Graduate and Rinconete
and Cortadillo.
Today, I'm going to speak about
The Deceitful Marriage
and The Dogs Colloquy,
two connected novels that wind
up the volume of The
Exemplary Novels or
Exemplary Stories.
I have trouble saying
Exemplary Stories because
it's just not stories,
it's novels,
or short novels.
So I may waiver,
but you know what I mean,
it's Novelas ejemplares
in Spanish,
not Exemplary Stories.
Now, as we approach these two
novels, we have to return to the
picaresque.
Now, let me summarize the
reasons why the picaresque was
so important in the development
of prose fiction and repeat
myself,
unless you think that I am
arbitrarily obsessed with this
kind of literature.
It's just that it is truly very
important for the development of
the novel.
Now, in the picaresque there is
for the first time,
except for
Celestina--but
Celestina was a dialogue,
a dramatic dialogue.
It was not a story with a
narrator,
and so forth--so in the
picaresque there is,
for the first time,
the representation of every day
life and common people,
with an emphasis on poor people
engaged in the struggle for
existence,
in a setting that is
contemporaneous with the author
and the reader;
both the author and the reader
recognize the setting as being
their own.
It's the present.
There is no fancy far away
geography, as in the romances of
chivalry, or the Byzantine
romances;
there is no remote time,
like the magical time of
fantastic stories;
the picaresque novels take
place in the here and now.
The protagonist is no hero by
conventional literary standards.
On the contrary,
he or she, because there are
feminine picaresques,
and we're going to be talking
about one today,
is a minor criminal in trouble
with the law,
and, in fact,
the center conceit of novels
like Lazarillo de Tormes
and Guzmán de
Alfareche is that the text
is a confession or deposition
addressed by the accused
delinquent to a figure in
authority.
So the picaresque is an
indictment of society written in
the form of the legal documents,
used by the authorities to
enmesh the pícaro
in the net of the law.
We saw how Don Quixote and
Sancho themselves are fugitives
from justice and are finally
apprehended by the trooper of
the Holy Brotherhood,
that funny trooper of the Holy
Brotherhood who cannot read very
well,
if you remember that hilarious
scene from Part I.
The picaresque makes possible
for the novel to depict
contemporary society and common
social types,
such as the ones appearing and
acquiring relevance in the
sixteenth and seventeenth
century,
as it is the beginnings of what
is a leveling of society that is
moving towards the eighteenth
century and the nineteenth
century,
and revolutions,
and so forth,
that we are very familiar with.
So these characters begin to
appear in novels,
as well as in paintings,
if you remember the paintings
by Velázquez that we have
looked at during the semester.
Rafael Salillas,
whom I have mentioned before
but I want to mention again,
Rafael Salillas,
a brilliant Spanish
criminologist of the late
nineteenth and early twentieth
century,
claimed that the picaresque was
the origin of the social
sciences,
specifically sociology and
criminology.
That is, sociology and
criminology find their source in
these kinds of novels,
these kinds of picaresque
novels that depict the lower
strata of society in great
detail.
He includes Cervantes' work
among those works that he places
at the origin of the social
sciences.
So it is, to me,
very suggestive,
then,
that Cervantes chose to wind up
his volume of Exemplary
Novels with these two
stories in the picaresque style.
Not picaresque per se,
because Cervantes never wrote a
picaresque novel in the strict
sense,
but novels with a picaresque
ambience and cast of characters.
Remember, this is a book you
only have a selection in your
book of translated stories.
The volume consists of a
prologue, parts of which are
included in my essay in the
Casebook about self
portraits, and then twelve
stories.
Remember, I talked about that
number because if The
Pretended Aunt was by
Cervantes,
maybe he didn't include it
because he didn't want the
number thirteen.
But in any case,
there are twelve stories and
these two,
The Deceitful Marriage
and The Dogs Colloquy are
the end,
The Deceitful Marriage
and The Dogs Colloquy,
and that's the end of the
volume.
The order of stories in such a
volume is always significant.
So, to me, it is significant
that the volume should end with
these two stories,
these interlocking stories,
too.
Now, as we saw with Roque
Guinart,
the Catalan bandit,
with Ginés de Pasamonte,
the galley slave,
and then later master
puppeteer,
and Monipodio in Rinconete
and Cortadillo,
Cervantes often pains a
sympathetic portrait of criminal
types.
At least, he never paints one
that is one-sidedly negative,
and he seems to have a liking
for these characters.
One reason may be that,
like Don Quixote,
who is also a delinquent--as we
know--
they represent original ways of
life,
different from mainstream
society, hence,
more interesting and appealing
from a literary point of view.
If you are good,
you're not interesting to
literature, for the most part.
So these criminal types are
interesting because they are
criminals, and they're
different, and they have
different lives that are quite
original.
We saw the same tendency in
Velázquez.
Velázquez paints dwarves
and near criminals,
and all of that,
because they are interesting,
different.
Also, criminal life--and this
would go back to Salillas--
could represent the origins of
societal of norms or how
societal norms develop,
norms that emerge out of the
clash of instincts,
desires, laws,
and so forth,
and this is why the criminals
are interesting.
If you follow the law and all
of that, you're not very
interesting.
The penchant for criminal types
found in the picaresque and in
Cervantes is something that will
become a staple of the novel;
especially the nineteenth
century novel is peopled by
criminals of all kind,
interesting,
sometimes appealing criminals
of all kinds,
like Jean Valjean, and so forth.
So we move to these stories,
The Deceitful Marriage,
El casamiento
engañoso, and The
Dogs Colloquy,
El coloquio de los
perros.
Now, notice that these two
stories,
one implanted into the other,
as it were,
follow the narrative device
called "the framed
tale," that is,
the tale within the tale.
It's a device that goes back to
the origins of story telling in
the Thousand and One Nights,
for instance.
Now, it allows Cervantes to
finish his volume of stories
with one of his cherished
infinitely receding sequences.
Remember, we've spoken about
these infinitely receding
sequences,
one within the other,
within the other,
I often use the example of the
little boy,
as I remember myself sitting in
a barber chair,
surrounded by mirrors,
and then seeing myself
disappear in the distance all
the images of myself,
and also the can of evaporated
milk that has depicted a can,
and so forth,
and so on, so this is what the
device is,
a story within the story.
They are like Chinese boxes,
one inside the other.
It is a form of closure,
if we're thinking that they
close or they finish the book
that denies closure as it were.
The volume is opened ended,
but it's open ended sort of
open on to itself,
there could be more,
and more, and more stories
down,
if you dug deeper into these
stories.
There could be yet another
story which,
indeed, there is one story that
is virtual or postponed in the
second story,
The Dogs Colloquy,
because the story of one of the
dog's life is not told,
so this is what I mean.
When I wrote an essay on this
many years ago I called it
"The Life of Scipio,"
saying that my essay was sort
of like the telling of this life
that was not told in the story.
Now, in The Deceitful
Marriage,
marriage is deconstructed,
as it were, both as a social
institution and as a narrative
tool.
We should read the story
against the backdrop of all of
the stories about marriage that
we have read in the
Quixote,
and also in the context of
The Pretended Aunt.
In fact, The Deceitful
Marriage is a story of
Cervantes that comes closest in
salaciousness to that contested
story,
The Pretended Aunt.
That is, it's the dirtiest of
Cervantes' stories,
if The Pretended Aunt is
not Cervantes'.
I'm sure you will agree with
me, and you will agree more with
me once you hear my reading of
it.
Estefanía,
the protagonist,
is a proactive female;
protagonist,
a female protagonist,
like others in Cervantes:
Dorotea, Marcela,
Zoraida.
Who charts her own course and
follows it with cunning and with
courage.
Of course, she is a prostitute,
but she is a proactive female
protagonist of Cervantes.
She dupes ensign Campuzano
luring him with her beauty and
pretended wealth--we could call
it--to whit her house.
Notice the detail,
I told you to look for details
in Cervantes.
How does she lure the ensign?
She has beautiful hands,
and that is the first thing
that the ensign notices when he
sees her.
Cervantes has sort of a fetish
for hands, and feet,
too, you remember Dorotea,
but mostly, Estefanía
has beautiful hands.
She traps him into marrying
her, but then it turns out she
was not the owner of the house.
That the true proprietors come
back and she scampers with the
jewels with which she thought he
had fooled her--
he thought that he had fooled
her, because he boasts that
they're counterfeit anyway,
the jewels that she steels.
It turns out,
however, that she had the last
laugh,
because she had infected him
with syphilis,
a kind of delayed action
counterblow,
by which she wins again.
It is clear that what
Estefanía did was her MO,
her modus operandi,
and that the ensign was neither
her first nor her last victim.
The cousin, the so-called
cousin, who's present at this
wedding, was obviously her pimp.
Well, not obviously,
Cervantes doesn't make things
that obvious,
but it is there.
Who was this guy?
Well, this guy is obviously her
pimp, and this is a routine that
they use to ensnare guys like
the ensign Campuzano.
He, of course,
thinks that he's also going to
have a good time,
and that he's going to fool
her, because he's making plans
to scamper and go back to war
once he has had enough of a good
time.
What is of interest to me in
the story is how Cervantes has
manipulated literary
conventions.
The story begins with a
marriage, virtually,
that is, it begins where
stories normally end,
and works backwards,
to undue a union that never
took place legitimately;
it is a marriage into which
they enter presumably without
pretense or illusions.
She tells him that she's no
virgin and that she has had her
life,
and this and that,
he doesn't care,
and he, of course,
is not a wealthy aristocrat by
any means,
and they know,
so they enter presumably
without illusions into this
marriage,
but the marriage,
of course, is based on worse
forms of deceit.
It also ends with an inversion
at the end that should have been
a beginning: the man is fooled,
and the woman flees.
In traditional stories,
it is the opposite:
the woman is fooled and the
man, the guy flees.
Marriages, as we have seen
throughout the semester,
are normally how stories end,
I repeat.
They bring closure to the
action representing the
restoration of order and the
continuation of the species.
Here, however,
Cervantes has inverted the
formula, the story begins with a
marriage.
As we have seen,
and I have said many times,
perhaps too many times
throughout the semester,
and it's not a warning to you,
everything that happens before
marriage is the stuff of comedy
in Cervantes,
everything that happens after
marriage is the stuff of
tragedy.
But here, surely because the
marriage is phony,
what follows is comical,
and worse.
The marriage,
by the way, would have been
annulled under Spanish law,
and even church canon law had
the ensign sued Estefanía
for misrepresenting herself:
she was not the owner of the
house,
and so forth.
But he could not sue her
because he,
too, had misrepresented his
wealth,
the jewels were counterfeit,
and he also had plans to quit
the premises as soon as he
could.
Now, the emblem of all of these
deceits is the house,
which should have,
on the contrary,
or normally,
provided the foundation of the
marriage.
It is in the house that they
spend a brief period of
matrimonial bliss.
This is the
engaño part that
precedes the
desengaño.
Legally and traditionally the
house is the concrete site of
marriage,
and in Spanish the word for
the word that is in the title
of the story is
"casamiento."
"Casa"
means "house"
in Spanish.
I like to add
"casa-
miento"
means "house-I-lie";
"miento"
from "mentir,"
"to lie,"
in Spanish;
it's a phony etymology that I
makeup.
It's also one of those things
that language--
gifts that language makes to
humor,
and the word for
"wife"
in Spanish,
as you probably know,
is "esposa,"
which is also the word for
"handcuffs."
I didn't invent the language,
and it is also a false
etymology.
In any case,
so the house is the emblem of
this house, casa-miento,
I lie.
The plot of The Deceitful
Marriage is indeed very,
very disturbing,
because it leads to total
disorder,
to a disillusion of the social
pact,
the social contract altogether,
it seems.
This is why I find it such a
disturbing story.
Husband and wife
disappear--they are not really
husband and wife--
one never to be heard from
again, Estefanía
vanishes,
she has to vanish,
like the galley slaves,
because probably the
authorities are after her,
and he winds up in the hospital
with a social disease from which
most people never recovered.
It is as if the story,
with this formal play of
inversions is hinting not at
tragedy,
but at something perhaps worse,
if that is possible,
the disappearance of old bones,
the unraveling of the discourse
that hold human society together
and organized.
This is what is hinted at,
by this very disturbing story.
Indeed, what follows is the
story of the ensign Campuzano in
the hospital,
and the hallucination that
leads him to write the next
story,
The Dogs Colloquy.
It is ironic,
in a way that I find more
bitter than is normal in
Cervantes that what leads to
literary creation here is not
just a social disease,
but the disease of love,
called at the time--
syphilis--was called at the
time in Spanish,
"el mal
francés,"
"the French disease."
I don't know why the Spanish
always blame the French for
everything having to do with
sex.
The love madness of courtly
love poets is literalized here,
love madness,
this is a love disease.
It literalizes a venereal
illness.
The Dogs Colloquy is
like Estefanía's and the
ensign's child;
it is the product of their
deceitful marriage.
This is I find a very
disturbing suggestion.
So we move to The Dogs
Colloquy.
Let me begin by considering the
names of the dogs,
the heroic Scipio,
Cipión in Spanish and
the picaresque Berganza.
These are the two dogs.
Historically,
there were two Scipios,
the one who took and destroyed
Carthage,
and his son,
who destroyed the Spanish town
of Numancia,
an event on which Cervantes
based perhaps his most
successful play.
So he knew well about Scipio.
Berganza is derived from
"bergante,"
slightly old-fashioned word
now.
"Bergante"
is a rogue, a rascal,
whereas, of course,
Scipio is a heroic name,
the name of a military
commander.
The two dogs make up a pair,
like Don Quixote and Sancho,
if you think of it,
the sort of picaresque type
Berganza and the military
Scipio.
Scipio's life,
the one not told,
is suggested that could have
been another Quixote,
but in a different key,
a Quixote in a canine key,
as it were.
It would be a mock heroic dog's
life, we could call it.
It's just suggested.
Now, ensign Campuzano's
predicament linking illness and
creativity is a spoof,
as I have said,
of the sick lover poet able to
compose poetry because of his
condition.
This will become a romantic
trope, only that here it is this
illness is dramatically and
literally an illness of love of
the lowest kind.
Remember, that the only cure,
other than some potions and
stuff, is to let him sweat it
out in this hospital,
and some survive,
but not too many.
Notice also,
the ironic name of the
hospital, I don't know if you
noticed it.
It's Hospital de la
Resurrección,
Hospital of the Resurrection
and this is out of--
through a kind of resurrection
ensign Campuzano comes out after
he has sweated out his syphilis,
or at least part of his
syphilis.
Now, Cervantes skirts here the
supernatural in the story,
the idea that dogs can talk.
The supernatural never appears
in Cervantes' works,
but he leaves open here the
possibility that the story of
the dogs talking is merely a
hallucination on the part of
Campuzano,
who's ill, and in his illness
and fever he imagines this.
It can also be a literary rouse
on the part of the ensign;
I mean, it is the character
within the story who is making
this up, Cervantes would say.
He wants to live in an
ambiguous state,
the origin of his literary
creation.
To me it is very suggestive.
I don't know if you found it
so, that he falls asleep while
his lawyer friend,
called Graduate Peralta in your
translation,
licenciado Peralta,
it means a lawyer;
he is a graduate in law.
I find it very suggestive that
the author falls asleep while
Peralta is reading his story.
As well, I mean it's also very
significant that the reader is
someone, a lawyer,
trained to read text and
ascertain the truthfulness.
This is sort of an ironic
reading scene,
no, the lawyer reading this to
tell whether it is true or not.
Now, on one level it is as if
the text belongs to the realm of
dreams,
the fact that he's sleeping,
and it is as if the reader is
tapping directly into his dreams
as he's sleeping.
It occurs to me,
because its author is asleep
while it's being read.
On another, it is as if there
is a gap between creator and the
text needed for the reader to
judge it independently.
That is, he's asleep,
he's no longer in control of
the text,
the text is now in the hands of
the reader,
and it is for the reader to
determine whether it is true or
not;
this is why he is asleep.
Of course, this is also a way
of having him do something while
the other one reads.
The other way would have been
to have him go to the market or
something,
but I think this is much more
interesting and suggestive,
the fact that he falls asleep.
I like to think of it as that
the reader is tapping directly
into his subconscious as he's
asleep.
Now, Peralta,
in a way, is a stand in for us,
the readers.
He offers a literary judgment
at the end,
pronouncing the story good,
though hardly believable,
and encouraging his friend to
go ahead and write the next
life.
Notice, in the context of my
discussion of the ending of
the Quixote in the last
lecture,
that life in here is the shape
of the story:
a life,
the life of Berganza,
and the next life is going to
be the life of Cipión,
of Scipio.
It is also, of course,
following in that the shape of
the picaresque that we saw when
we discussed the figure of
Ginés de Pasamonte,
who's written his life in
prison, and so forth,
and so on.
Now, there is more than a hint,
too, that the story that the
ensign tells or writes through
the dog is an encoded
autobiography.
This is a picaresque
autobiography in which the
pícaro pretends to
be a dog.
It's very ingenious and
inventive turn on Cervantes'
part.
Why is it autobiographical?
Particularly,
because when he takes the
manuscript from his pocket he
takes it out of his seno.
"Seno"
means his "bosom";
he's taking it out of his heart
in a way, so this suggests to me
that this is ensign Campuzano's
story, but told deflected into
the life of this dog.
It is very interesting that
literature issues out of these
tawdry living conditions and
figures,
literary creation,
as it did in the case of
Ginés de Pasamonte,
who wrote his life while he was
in prison,
and also in the case of
Cervantes himself who's life,
if not quite as tawdry,
sometimes was like that when he
was a prisoner,
a captive, in Algiers,
and the couple of times when he
was really in jail in Spain for
irregularities in his accounts
when he was collecting for the
Spanish Armada,
and so forth.
So I think this is Cervantes'
take on the origins of modern
literature;
it originates in these
conditions and out of figures
like these.
Now, the point is that he's
showing the virtual workings of
the literary imagination,
which deflects the real and the
tawdry or the seedy life of the
ensign,
and deflect it into the life of
the dog,
which has a slightly classical
form because of the fables where
dogs speak,
and so forth,
that are mentioned in the text.
Now, the uncertain origin of
the dogs who could also be the
transformed sons of that witch,
in that marvelous scene with
the witches that I am sure you
remember,
and that allude or harken back
to Celestina,
or they could have been simply
dogs born, where?
in the slaughterhouse of
Seville, remember,
Seville is the capital of
picaresque life and the
slaughterhouse seems to be the
capital within the capital of
picaresque life.
But it also--Cervantes' is also
leaving the origin of the story
in an air of indeterminacy,
sort of like Don Quixote's
origins.
I think that the significance
of the ending of the story,
again, back to the infinitely
receding sequences,
is that it brings about no
closure at all to the volume.
So we make a little digression
here before we get towards the
end of the lecture to discuss
Kafka's parable,
that I hope you read for today.
Kafka, 1883-1924 as we all know
as a Czech author who wrote in
German such masterpieces as
The Metamorphoses,
1915, The Trial,
1925, The Castle,
1926 in which he presented a
world ruled by arbitrary and
mysterious bureaucratic laws,
by which the characters seem to
abide impelled by obscure
forces.
He never published his work,
which he ordered that it be
destroyed upon is death,
a wish that fortunately was not
followed.
I think that this brief text,
it's just a paragraph shows to
what extent Kafka,
I think, connected with the
core of Cervantes' literary
imagination,
with Cervantes' notion and feel
for literary creativity.
The text is entitled,
"The Truth about Sancho
Panza" and it says:
"Without making any boast
of it,
Sancho Panza succeeded in the
course of years by feeding him a
great number of romances of
chivalry and adventure in the
evening and night hours,
in so diverting from himself
his demon,
whom he later called Don
Quixote, that this demon
thereupon set out uninhibited on
the maddest exploits,
which however for the lack of a
pre ordained object which should
have been Sancho Panza himself,
harmed nobody.
A free man Sancho Panza
resignedly followed Don Quixote
in his crusades,
perhaps out of a sense of
responsibility and had of them a
great and edifying entertainment
to the ends of his days."
That's the parable on the truth
of Sancho Panza.
So I think that Kafka is
turning Cervantes' fiction
upside down,
but within the spirit of
Cervantes,
by making Sancho the inventor
of Don Quixote and following him
around afterwards.
The whole fiction comes out of
Sancho's demon,
that is, the demon of a common
man,
like those, both Kafka and
Cervantes like to invent--
The Glass Graduate,
for example,
is another common man--and also
like other authors in Cervantes,
Sancho's creation gets out of
hand,
and acquires a life of its own.
I think this is Kafka's reading
of Cervantes,
I think it is a very profound
reading even if it is or perhaps
because it is so brief.
I also wish to mention the
Borges story,
Pierre Menard,
Author of the Quixote,
which is one of the most famous
stories by Borges,
in which, as you remember,
this French poet,
minor poet, decides to rewrite
the Quixote,
not just rewrite the
Quixote,
but word by word,
as Cervantes had written it,
the idea being that it is much
more difficult to write the
Quixote in seventeenth
century Spanish,
especially by a Frenchman than
it was for Cervantes to write in
his own time,
and so forth.
It is a big literary joke on
the part of Borges,
but at the same time,
Borges is unsettling the
romantic notion of the link
between creator and work,
which he shows he cannot
completely unsettle it,
because Pierre Menard dies
because of the effort it took to
do this which,
of course, he could never
finish.
It's an impossible task that he
sets for himself.
Borges was also reacting,
in 1939, when he wrote the
story,
to what he considered to be
sort of proto-fascist readings
of the Quixote by Spanish
scholars.
Remember, the Spanish Civil War
is just over,
and the promotion of
hispanidad,
the Spanishness,
and so forth,
and he's trying to show that
Cervantes' great creation
doesn't belong to any single
language or any single national
tradition,
but that it can be,
potentially,
can be written or rewritten by
anyone.
Also, he is underlining
something that he himself said
with Cervantean self
depreciation,
that once you write something
that is good,
it doesn't belong to you any
more, it belongs to the
tradition,
and so this is what it says,
the Cervantes creation has
escaped him,
because it now belongs to the
tradition,
not to Cervantes.
This is something that Borges
said.
Now, let us finish by talking a
bit about Cervantes' death,
going back to the beginning of
today's class.
I think that Cervantes
identified with the death of Don
Quixote and Alonso Quijano.
I think that there is an
identification with them,
because he feels that life as
fiction has to come to an end,
and a form of truth must be
reached on the brink of death.
It is a form of truth for which
ironically literature has
prepared him through the
understanding of
desengaño.
Cervantes seems to be saying
that he, like Don Quixote,
is renouncing a life of make
belief, so what is the sense of
the novel's ending?
Perhaps it is the feeling of
sadness,
of regret, that the book,
the madness,
the entertainment,
and the fun,
have to come to an end,
like everything else.
It is not so much sense as
meaning, as sense as feeling,
not sentido as
significado but
sentido as
sentimiento.
It's in the sense that Unamuno
uses the word sentimiento
in the The Tragic Sense of
Life.
So this is the sense of the
ending of the Quixote,
it is a sense of sadness
redolent with potential
meanings,
but these are meanings that we
cannot decipher all together.
Now, in the prologue to the
Persiles which is
Cervantes' farewell,
he presents himself as a man
resigned to his impending death,
and content with his
accomplishments,
going back to what Durán
had said in the quote at the
very beginning of my lecture.
The text is Cervantes' farewell.
The dedication to
Persiles,
the dedication,
not the prologue,
but they must have been
contemporaneous,
contemporary to each other,
was April 19th,
1616, the dedication,
that is, four days before his
death.
He says that he was given the
extremunction,
which is the last rights in the
Catholic Church,
and then he writes the
following.
I hope I have it here;
I do, I do...
Yes.
So, I am going to read it,
it takes five minutes,
in Spanish, and then I'm going
to read it in English.
Apologies to those who cannot
follow it in Spanish,
because I'm going to say
something about the rhythm of
the prose, and I want you to
hear it:
"Sucedió,
pues, lector amantísimo,
que, viniendo otros dos amigos
y yo del famoso lugar de
Esquivias,
por mil causas famoso,
una por sus ilustres linajes y
otra por sus ilustrísimos
vinos,
sentí
que a mis espaldas venía
picando con gran prisa uno que,
al parecer, traía deseo
de alcanzarlos,
y aún lo mostró
dándonos voces,
que no picásemos tanto.
Esperámosle,
y llegó
sobre una borrica un estudiante
pardal,
porque todo venía
vestido de pardo,
antiparras, zapato redondo y
espada con contera,
valona bruñida y con
trenzas iguales.
Verdad es que no traía
más de dos,
porque se le venía a un
lado la valona por un momentos,
y él traía sumo
trabajo y cuenta de enderezarla.
Llegando a nosotros
dijo:-¿Vuesas mercedes
van a alcanzar algún
oficio o prebenda a la corte,
pues allá
está su
Ilustrísima de Toledo,
y su Majestad,
ni más ni menos,
según la priea con que
caminan,
que en verdad que a mi burra se
le ha cantado el víctor
de caminante más de una
vez.
A lo cual respondió
uno de mis compañeros:
-El rocín del
señor Miguel de Cervantes
tiene la culpa de esto,
porque es algo pasilargo.
Apenas hubo oído el
estudiante el nombre de
Cervantes,
cuando, apeándose de su
cabalgadura,
cayéndosele aquí
el cojín y allí
el portamanteo,
que con toda esa autoridad
caminaba,
arremetió a mí y,
acudiendo asirme de la mano
izquierda,
dijo: '¡Sí,
sí;
éste es el manco sano,
el famoso todo,
el escritor alegre y,
finalmente, el regocijo de las
musas!'
Yo, que en tanto espacio vi el
grande encomio de mis alabanzas,
parecióme ser
descortesía no
corresponder a ellas,
y así,
abrazándole por el
cuello,
donde le eché
a perder de todo punto la
valona,
le dije: 'Ése es un
error donde han caído
muchos aficionados ignorantes.
Yo, señor,
soy Cervantes,
pero no el regocijo de las
musas, ni ninguno de las
demás baratijas que ha
dicho vuesa merced;
vuelva a cobrar su burra y
suba, y caminemos en buena
conversación lo poco que
nos falta de camino.'
Hízolo así
el comedido estudiante,
tuvimos algún tanto
más las riendas,
y con paso asentado seguimos
nuestro camino,
en el cual se trató
de mi enfermedad,
y el buen estudiante me
desahució
al momento,
diciendo: 'Esta enfermedad es
de hidropesía,
que no la sanará
toda el agua del mar
océano que dulcemente se
bebiese,
vuesa merced,
señor Cervantes,
ponga tasa al beber,
no olvidándose de comer,
que con esto sanará
sin otra medicina alguna.'
'Esto me han dicho muchos'
respondí
yo,
'pero así
puedo dejar de beber a todo mi
beneplácito,
como si para sólo eso
hubiese nacido.
Mi vida se va acabando,
y, al paso de las
efemérides de mis pulsos,
que, a más tardar,
acabarán su carrera este
domingo,
acabaré yo la de mi vida.
En fuerte punto ha llegado
vuestra merced a conocerme,
pues no me queda espacio para
mostrarme agradecido a la
voluntad que vuesa merced me ha
mostrado.'
En esto llegamos a la puente de
Toledo,
y yo entré
por ella [they are going into
Madrid],
y él se apartó
al entrar por la de Segovia.
Lo que se dirá
de mi suceso,
tendrá
la fama cuidado,
mis amigos gana de decirlo,
y yo mayor gana de escucharlo.
Tornéle a abrazar,
volvióseme a ofrecer,
picó a su burra,
y dejóme tan mal
dispuesto como él iba
caballero en su burra,
a quien había dado gran
ocasión a mi pluma para
escribir donaires;
pero no son todos los tiempos
unos: tiempo vendrá,
quizá,
donde, anudando este roto hilo,
diga lo que aquí
me falta,
y lo que sé
convenía.
Adiós, gracias;
adiós, donaires;
adiós,
regocijados amigos;
que yo me voy muriendo,
y deseando veros presto
contentos en la otra vida."
Which goes, in English,
I hope without an interruption
like the one we had before.
You catch the setting,
he's going into Madrid,
where the court is,
this is what he alludes to:
"It so happens dearest
reader as two friends and I were
coming from the famous town of
Esquivias [which is where his
wife was from]
famous for a thousand reasons
one of them being its
illustrious families and another
its even more illustrious wines
that I perceived someone behind
me sparing his mount on in a
great hurry.
He apparently wanted to
overtake us and soon made that
clear by calling out for us not
to spur on so urgently.
We waited for him,
and on a she-ass up came a drab
student,
drab because he came dressed
all in rustic brown with
leggings,
round toed shoes,
a sword in a chapped scabbard
and a starch laced collar with
is matching ties.
The fact of the matter is that
he only had two of these ties to
hold it on,
so every other minute the
collar kept falling over to one
side and he was at great pains
to keep it straight.
Catching up to us he said,
'You sirs must be on your way
to court to obtain some office
or benefits from his most
illustrious grace of Toledo and
his majesty themselves are
doubtless there,
judging by the hurry with which
you are traveling,
since even my ass,
which has been praised more
than once for her speed couldn't
catch to you.'
To this, one of my companions
replied, 'It's the fault of
Señor Miguel de
Cervantes' nag,
which is somewhat
long-stepping.'
Scarcely had the student heard
the name Cervantes when he
dismounted from his pack animal
sending his saddlebags flying in
one direction and his valise in
another.
He traveled so completely
outfitted and rushed up to me,
seizing my left hand and
saying, 'Yes,
yes, this is the complete
cripple, the completely famous
and comic writer and lastly the
delight of the muses.'
I, who in so short a space of
time saw such great complements
in my praise,
felt it would have been
discourteous not to respond to
them,
and so, embracing him around
the neck,
where by I destroyed his collar
all together,
I said to him,
'That is an error into which
many of my uninformed admirers
have fallen.
I sir, am Cervantes,
but not the delight of the
muses or any other foolish
things that you mentioned.
Round up your ass,
mount up, and let's pass the
brief remainder of our journey
in pleasant conversation.'
The obliging student did just
that;
we reigned in slightly and then
resumed our trip at a more
leisurely pace.
As we traveled,
we talked about my illness,
and the good student
immediately diagnosed me a
hopeless case,
saying, 'This sickness is
dropsy incurable even if you
were to drink all of the waters
of the ocean sea made sweet.
Señor Cervantes, sir,
you should limit your drinking
and don't forget to eat,
for thereby you will recovery
without any other medicine.'
'That's what many have told
me', I replied,
'but I just can't give up the
pleasure of drinking all I want
for it almost seems I was born
to it.
My life's race is slowing at
the rate of my pulse,
and by this Sunday at the
latest it will complete its
course and with it my life.
You sir, have made my
acquaintance at a difficult
moment, for there isn't enough
time left to express my
gratitude for the goodwill
you've shown me.'
At this point,
we arrived at the Toledo
bridge, where I crossed into the
city and he road off to enter by
the Segovia road.
As to what may be said of this
incident fame will take care to
report it,
my friends will take pleasure
in telling it and I even more
pleasure in hearing it.
Once again, we embraced each
other, he spurred his mount and
left me just as ill at ease as
he was in trying to be a
gentleman on that ass.
He had afforded my pen a great
opportunity to be witty,
but you can't always make one
moment what you can of another.
The time had come perhaps when
I shall tie up this broken
thread and say what I fail to
hear and what would have been
fitting,
goodbye humor,
goodbye wit,
goodbye merry friends,
for I am dying and hope to see
you soon happy in the life to
come."
Here we find the same Cervantes
of the Quixote prologues.
These are the five points that
I want to make.
One, the prologue as dialogue,
as in Part I,
and throughout Cervantes' work,
instead of an expository piece
in the first person,
he needs to create another to
tell the story of his own self.
Why?
Do these dialogues reflect
those going on in his own mind?
They do reflect his ironic
stance before his own sense of
self,
and before his own sense of the
truth,
because it is sort of this
perspectivism that we have seen.
Two, here, as so many times in
the Quixote,
we have another student,
with hilarious details about
his clothing.
Students are seekers of
knowledge, readers which are of
great interest to Cervantes,
as we all know.
The details,
as all details in Cervantes,
are revealing of character,
of personality.
This is a very economical way
of talking about this guy's
personality by showing his
vanity with all of his clothes
that he's wearing.
Three, the scene takes place on
the road, symbol of time and of
life as in the Quixote.
Four--and I think this is the
subtlest and this is why I
wanted you to hear it in my
interrupted reading in Spanish--
the rhythm of prose,
and of the story itself seems
to echo that of the trotting
horses;
this trotting of the horses and
the various paces that the
horses follow are marking time,
and time, its fleetingness is
the theme of the piece life's
race and life's journey coalesce
as death approaches and is
marked by the trotting of the
horses and by the rhythm of the
prose.
Five, Cervantes deals
ironically with his late fame,
which comes when he's near
death.
It's something out of rhythm
because now it is of little
consolation or profit for him.
So we have here the same self
deprecating Cervantes that we
have learned to love.
Now, it is in that same spirit
that I ask him,
or wherever he happens to be,
and I ask you forgiveness for
my own shortcomings in
commenting his work.
Thank you very much.